[Applause]
thank you
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
u.s. Institute of Peace my name is Nancy
lindborg I'm the president of US IP and
I am absolutely delighted to welcome
here this afternoon for her first visit
to u.s. IP mrs. Bush we're very happy to
have you here and I also want to welcome
ambassador Moe [ __ ] from F Islamic
Republic of Afghanistan and mrs. muhib
delighted to have you here with us and
we have many other guests here in the
room thank you for joining us thank you
for coming this afternoon and for those
of you who are new to us IP we are an
independent National Institute founded
by Congress 30 years ago and dedicated
to the proposition that peace is
possible peace is practical and peace is
essential for US and international
security and we pursue a vision of a
world without violent conflict by
working in conflict zones with partners
equipping them with tools with knowledge
and with training and there's probably
no place where US IP teams have spent
more time than in Afghanistan working
with civil society and government
partners to help make peace possible so
we're delighted to have today a panel
discussion to discuss exactly who are
some of the powerful women helping to
make peace possible in Afghanistan and I
have the distinct privilege of
introducing our panelists and our
moderator let me note that we will have
uh sure 'he's coming down the aisle to
collect your question cards for
questions after opening remarks if you
have a question please write down your
name your affiliation along with your
question on the card and we will make
sure that gets on stage so first let me
welcome mrs. Laura Bush former First
Lady of the United States she has long
been an advocate for expanding the
rights and the opportunities of women in
Afghan
Stan she's traveled to more than 76
countries inter including two historic
solo trips to Afghanistan and today as
the chair of the Women's Initiative at
the George W Bush Institute mrs. Bush
continues her work on global healthcare
innovation empowering women in emerging
democracies education reform and in
supporting the men and women who have
served in America's military we also
have with us today MS Meena share Zoi
who's a gender activist with more than
25 years of experience in economic
development and advocacy and Miss chair
zoe has extensive experience in
capacity-building and NGO development
and Afghanistan she's worked with the
Afghan Civil Service Commission and
government counterparts to increase
women's participation in government and
currently she serves as Kim onyx
Afghanistan based senior gender adviser
and is also featured in the wonderful
new book that we're here to celebrate by
mrs. Bush finally I'm delighted to
introduce mr. Stephen Hadley who
currently serves as the chair of u.s.
ip's Board of Directors as our wise
counsel and champion previously Steve
was the assistant to the president at
the national security affairs for four
years to then president george w bush
and from january 2001 to 2005 he was
assistant to the president and deputy
security adviser please join me in
giving a very warm welcome to our three
wonderful guests
[Applause]
all right we're delighted that all of
you can be with us and of course mrs.
Bush we are delighted to have you here
at the u.s. Institute of Peace and
delighted with your new book which is a
series of and a collection of wonderful
stories and if you haven't read it you
really need to do so it's a it's a
terrific book what we're gonna do this
afternoon is we're going to have a
conversation among mrs. Bush Mina and
myself for about 25 minutes or so and
then we're going to have a question and
answer period from you there are cards
that have been distributed please write
your questions on the cards pass them to
the aisles and there are we runners
coming down and getting them and passing
up to to me and we will try to get
through as many questions as we can
we'll then at the end turn to our our
panelists if you will and ask for any
closing comments and then we will we'll
adjourn promptly at at 5 o'clock so
again we're delighted that you're all
with us here for this wonderful event I
want to start this Bush with you if I
might you have a long history of being a
real advocate and champion for Afghan
women you were the first first lady to
deliver the presidential radio address
in November of 2001 and you spoke about
the plight challenges and and the
strength of Afghan women at that time
why is this such a cause for you of all
the things you could take on his first
lady as a cause why had was Afghan women
so important to you during your tenure
as first lady well right after September
11th when the spotlight turned on
Afghanistan American women including
myself saw women who were marginalized
who were left out and the very idea of a
government that would forbid half of its
population from being educated was
shocking to Americans American men and
women but a lot of people started
calling
me to say I want to do something what
can I do to help and one of my best
friends from Houston called and said I
used to be so glad I wasn't in your
shoes but she said now wish I were I'm
jealous because you can do something and
I can't so right then we formed the u.s.
Afghan Women's Council and many American
women thought of various projects to to
support our sisters in Afghanistan and
that was really the beginning of my
interest in Afghanistan and in the women
there so all the years that we lived at
the White House and since I've stayed in
contact with many women that I've met
through the u.s. Afghan Women's Council
are met on my trips to Afghanistan I
wanted to write about him and you said
you wanted to write about them why this
book in in this way by the way if you
haven't seen it it has a forward from
mrs. Bush it's a wonderful real precis
of the tribulations of Afghanistan over
the last 25 years it's wonderfully
written but why this book in this
particular way well it's called voices
of hope and these are the stories of
women in Afghanistan and because their
voices were silenced I thought it was
important for - for all of us to hear
what they had to say besides that I
think the things have changed since
September 11th and things have changed
since that first time I visited
Afghanistan and I wanted people to know
that so I think this is a great way for
all of us to learn not only about each
of these women and one man one brave man
included - his stories his story but
also for us to learn more about the
industry of Afghanistan I think we think
we know it all but their lives really
show the history of the last say 40
years of Afghanistan starting with for
many of them when the Soviets came in in
1979 and at that point some of these
women's immigrated to Pakistan with
their families
ended up in the united states after that
but nearly all of them went back after
September 11th when they could go back
some live there the whole time through
the years of the Soviet occupation and
then the years of the Taliban and her
still there but I think I wanted to tell
their stories I wanted Americans to hear
their stories and I'm thrilled I had
this opportunity to tell their stories
with this book you know you're one of
the people in that book you were born in
Afghanistan came to the United States
spent most of your young adult life in
the United States until 9/11 which was
traumatic for all of us and so September
11 2001 you decided to go back to
Afghanistan tell us about your decision
to return to Afghanistan and what you've
been doing there and your life there now
that you have returned in first Hill and
why you were in Afghanistan when was it
when the Soviets came in that yes I was
in there yes well first of all I want to
thank you and I'm very privileged to be
here on the stage with you mrs. Bush and
mr. Hadley and I want to thank u.s. IP
as always to putting together such a
dynamic events and thanking everybody to
be a part of this who are here today I
was young had just graduated graduated
from high school Tohono High School in
Kabal and my father was a diplomat and
we were in Czechoslovakia he was an
ambassador at that time and it just the
we heard that the Russians took over
which was a shock and it came in in such
a shock that at first we didn't know you
know like okay they invaded the country
I was so young I didn't know the meaning
of it because of honest on it that I
liked I was raised in the golden ages
you know we didn't think of war I had
never seen a gun before or a tank or
anything else so to me it was like okay
the somebody invaded
they will leave and we will go back so
we slowly immigrated to the United
States even my father had the attitude
that after three years we will go back
and the American ambassador in Germany
gave my father he was going to give him
citizenship green card everything he
said no no no no I'm not gonna do that
I'm going back in three years so to make
a long story short we ended up staying
for 25 years the September 11th happened
and when September 11 happened of course
my father was one of the first people
that went to Havana son and he was the
deputy political foreign minister so I
saw the opportunity because a lot of
people were telling me don't go don't go
it's dangerous
but deep inside all these 25 years I had
such a passion to go back and I always
thought of the Afghan people being there
and suffering and I always thought of
having I mean thankful and grateful for
having all the opportunities that I had
in the United States so how could I
reach them and so there was three of us
three women one was in Carmel - one
wasn't in May in fact that I lived in
California so in the Bay Area so the
three of us decided to start doing
fundraising for the Afghan women and we
did fund readings before - because I
used to do a lot of fundraising and
raise two thousand three thousand
dollars and send them to the camps the
best I can do but this time it was
different the fundraising was like the
doors had opened so it's time to go now
time to go and give time to go and help
and take people's hands and whatever the
darkness has been in the past let's
overcome that so that's why I've always
wanted to go back but until September
11th I couldn't because of the war and
the Taliban and
was going on but after that I decided to
go back yes and what was it like when
you went back what was your first
reactions what was the in the
environment after 2001 and then tell us
a little bit about the environment now I
think being raised in the golden days
during the golden days of one Sun and
then being I'm really grateful for
living in America and to be honest with
you I cherished my life here because
America I gave me security peace
serenity education opportunities
everything and I went there actually to
be honest with you for three weeks
because I had two daughters I have two
two daughters and they were going to
college at that time so I said I'm going
for three or four weeks and I'll be back
which I've never returned and so when I
went back one thing that I saw that
triggered my heart in my mind at the
same time because when I landed they
took me the driver in my cousin they
took me to the American Embassy to
register for security reasons being an
American citizen you had to register so
I got out of the car and everything was
done on the street at that time so it
was a bit of time so I went ahead and
started signing the papers and talking
to the soldiers and and I turned around
this was actually March 14th when I
landed there so I turned around I saw
this 10 year old boy or nine year old
boy in a raggedy clothes barefoot and it
was kind of chilly and he was polishing
my cousin's shoes for a dollar I just
saw that and I totally freaked out right
there and because I started thinking how
I was raised when I was 10 years old my
niece's my daughters my family my
parents my friends kids when they're 10
years old they're in another world
they're not even when they grow older as
parents we ask them to polish our shoes
they never help polish my shoes even now
but that broke my heart right there so
what I did the next thing I did was
after a week after studying everything I
went to my I called my daughter's I said
look there are people here I have been
around there girls that haven't been to
school they're your age they can't even
write their name so I know you need me
I'm your mother
I'll always be there for you but do you
mind if I can stay here for a few years
and help and take care of these girls
and guide them in a system in whatever
way I can
so they were so supportive and I always
feel them I said no no you just wanted
to get rid of a nagging mom but they
said no we knew your passion we heard
you on the phone and we when we have
time we will come and help you so I'm
really appreciative that yes otherwise I
couldn't have been there and a word
about the situation now the situation
now has changed as we all know we see
through the newspapers I just came back
on Wednesday things have changed and
I've honest not drastically if you look
at it from 14 15 years ago when you look
at women empowerment education health
clinics hospitals the judiciary system I
mean everything is not a hundred percent
perfect but at least the seeds have been
planted there let's put it this way the
only thing that's really a barrier to
development of any country or anything
you do in life is security their
insecurity in corruption to things like
for example violation against women I'll
give you an example of that first of all
the there is justice system in
Afghanistan we have a lot of good laws
but there is no way of enforcing it
enforcing it in the mean because of
corruptions get them in the way so what
I saw this time I was there for three
months I had I went again for three
weeks I ended up for three months so the
security situation has really
deteriorated and I know a lot of
businesses are closing a lot of people
are becoming unemployed so this kind of
situation adds to the insecurity as well
because when something happens when
something goes wrong you don't know it
was the talib it was - it was the teeth
it was the person who was hungry you
don't know who did it so right now
that's where things are the security
situation but even though let's put it
this way the security situation has
deteriorated but we keep pushing things
we don't stop thank you Miss Bush you
went to Afghanistan in 2005 then again
2006 2008 can you talk a little bit
about those trips what you learned some
of the insights you had and perhaps some
of the women that you met during those
trips some of them probably show up in
here in your book now and once when I
went to Bamiyan province and met the
female governor there and Bamiyan is the
province that had the two huge towering
6th century buddhas that were carved
into niches in the mountain wall and I
knew what they look like from
photographs but by the time I went
they've been destroyed and they were
just rubble at the bottom of these two
huge niches that had been there since
the 6th century but then destroyed by
the Taliban so there was this contrast
between the ancient civilization of
Afghanistan with these old Buddha's that
had been destroyed and then the the idea
that there was a female governor which
was the newer thing newer since
September 11th and I remember coming to
see her and what that was like and how
thrilled I was to be there and
I see her but then also this big symbol
of them the destruction of the ancient
palimony really of Afghanistan and did
you meet some of the women at that time
that are in your book now I met most of
the women that are in the book here in
the US through various things here Rossi
and John who's here let's see where they
there she is over there and others whose
stories are mean obviously whose story
is here I've read when I've been on the
book tour I've read from Mina's the
story the the what she just told us the
story have seen the little boy without
shoes polishing the shoes of someone
else and have that struck her in that
picture stayed in her mind and led her
to want to uh spend so much time there
so I've formed a lot of friendships with
women in Afghanistan and it's been
really I mean and some of them are in
the year some of the women in this book
I don't know but they are there are a
few of them here as well today you know
I'd like to go back to something you
started there's a lot of intermittent
press coverage here about Afghanistan
most of it bad you know security is
getting bad Taliban are on the move and
all the rest and I think we don't often
appreciate how far the country has come
and you started to talk a little bit
about that could you say a little bit
more about what has really been
accomplished here in the last fourteen
years or so like I said earlier we have
accomplished a lot for 15 years ago we
didn't have girls going to school we
didn't have clinics for women we didn't
have women ministers we didn't have
women in Parliament so I can go on and
on especially business women women
advocates the first year when I was
there let me let me let me explain it to
you this way when I first went there I
was looking for women to that they're
doing the hand
craft in the carpet weaving and all that
so I was looking for them all over the
place and you couldn't find them even in
burkas on the streets so I ran into this
mullah and I kept asking I just want to
see like 10 or 15 women that I could
work with and I could talk to and maybe
I could teach them some stairs if our
economic empowerment purposes he said
okay why don't you come on a Friday and
I will go ahead and show you the 15 and
20 women so you can work with them I
kind of didn't tell anybody where I was
going because I know if I tell my dad I
was going to this mosque he will send
ten guards with me or he won't let me go
so I was afraid but I did go with my
friends and to be honest with you I
walked into that mosque I had I saw
hundreds hundreds of women with burqa
sitting there and they were back was
facing me when I entered and I stood
there I said you got to be kidding me
what am I gonna do with this hundreds
and hundreds of women so I stood there I
pretty much give them a message and
talked to them saying that I'm here to
help
I'm here to empower them I'm so that
they are not needy they are not a
charity case anymore because I'm very
against a big becoming a charity case
for the Afghan women so you have to
learn you have to work and earn your
money in order to raise your children
help your family and husband and
everyone so I lived there that's what
encouraged me to put together an NGO so
I put together an NGO for widows
especially and I registered over 10,000
women and in six years then we did an
assessment and to be honest in 10,000
women I had only 56 literate women
that's only highschool I'm talking high
school which is some of them were eighth
grade ninth grade so the dirac are
literate and so this is what happened
and then I was able to get you know
funds from the
and institutions donors and I did the
capacity-building and tailoring sewing
and English and literacy and computer
classes as we started expanding but
looking today you see a lot of Afghan
women out there this is what I'm trying
to compare at that on that time you know
you couldn't find anybody but now you
find hundreds and thousands of women out
there even in the provinces or in Kabul
and on media for example you see them on
television the journalists the teachers
I mean they're all over the place so
it's not that difficult to find out
young women now thank God one of the
things that mrs. Bush's forward there
some very nice statistics showing the
progress on health and education one
that struck me I think it teenage girls
now 36 percent literacy 37 percent of
the teachers in Afghanistan are now
women so really remarkable progress and
mrs. Bush I know one of the things that
the at the Institute and the
Presidential Library you have been very
instrumental in the women's initiative
at the bush Institute continuing the
work you started as first lady what
kinds of activities are going on in that
project within the bush Institute well
at the bush Institute we had four
classes of women fellow fellowships to
from Egypt and to from Tunisia we began
with those two countries because they
were the first and most active in the
Arab Spring countries that we bring
women all from the same country for a
fellowship so that when they go home
they have each other and they can
introduce each other to their colleagues
and their families and their friends and
thereby broaden their networks there's
an SMU professor who did research that
shows that your network is as important
as your education level to your success
and in societies where women are inside
more they didn't have the chance to
build the kind of networks that we as
American women do so we've had now for
classes to Egyptian class listen to
Tunisian of fellows and we'll do another
group this year of Egyptian fellows and
our idea is just to continue to focus on
these two so when they go home they
really have a broad network now with the
two groups and and and everybody else
they've introduced each other too so
that's one of the things that we're
working on as part of our Women's
Initiative we have a Women's Health
Initiative we in Africa we've added the
testing and treatment for cervical
cancer which is the leading cause of
cancer death among African women to the
PEPFAR platform the AIDS platform that
was set up when George was president the
President's Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief that's all across Africa now it's
really helped Africans build a health
infrastructure with PEPFAR money
treating aids to start with but now
adding the testing and treatment for
cervical cancer to to that so that's our
global health initiative which of course
is focused on women as well we have a
first lady's initiative we began with
conferences in Africa with African first
lady's to talk about how they can use
their roles in their countries while
their husbands are ahead of state to
work on issues that are important to
them we've tried to match them with NGOs
or corporations that are active in their
countries and then talked about good
governance the one one African woman
said well I know the government paid for
your clothes and we said no they didn't
melanda there happened to be there she
immediately said no they did not
thinking about missus clinton but but we
do talk about good governance in the
ways that first ladies can help and now
we've broaden that to more than just
african first ladies we have the first
lady's initiative with first lady's from
all around the world what else
piers charity she's the head of our
Women's Initiative Pittman Bush
Institute oh and then of course that USF
in Women's Council we just which we just
came from a meeting of here so African I
mean Afghan first ladies are part of our
projects as well working with Afghan
women and that's obvious I mean that's
what this book is and that's why I would
wear here today and one of the things I
thought is nice is it really is a I was
honored had the privilege of sitting in
on the meeting today it is a bipartisan
effort I mean this is one area where
Republicans and Democrats have worked
together and I thought it was
interesting that former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton wrote a nice blurb
on the back of the and I think it
continues to be a bipartisan effort here
by the American people by in the
Congress and that's a wonderful thing
mean I'd like to go back to you if I
might and just ask you what is the sort
of the frame of mind the spirit of
Afghan women today what are they
thinking about what are their their
hopes particularly the young women who
have who have seen such change in their
lives what's you know when you talk to
them what's their frame of mind today
what are their hopes what are their
fears the frame of mind of Afghan women
like I said earlier it has changed
through the time of the first of the
passport that in the past 14 years
they're not the same Afghan woman that
they were 14 years ago they have come a
long way they are they have learned
their right in every way and there's
learning I'm not saying if the whole
country knows all the women they know
their rights but they're still right
learning and the other thing is they
have learned how to add advocate and
their spirit is high all the time one
thing I found about young women no
matter if it was the golden ages of
honest on or the bad days for it doesn't
matter where they are how they are how
bad it is they have a high spirit
they're very brave
they're very courageous and they have
this strong inner hope that it keeps
them going all the time I have seen
women that has really been through a lot
of hardship and it just surprises me
that how she comes to work the next day
with a smile on her face and still you
don't know what she has been through and
it's that mask that she wears I call it
it's that mask that she wears in order
to look strong to move on and to in
convinced her children and her family
it's okay that everything would be fine
and of course just like everybody else
Afghan women are like they like the
other women in the end the world we're
not any different than the odd young
women it is just the differences what
kind of opportunities are given to them
and what kind of opportunities are given
to us and that's the difference and the
second security also plays a major role
for them so Afghan women and overall
they're in high spirits and their dream
is to be just like everybody else
a normal mother normal wife normal
citizen and they just want to live just
like everybody else
even though like I said things are
really getting rough these days but I
don't know if you have seen the news and
all that how they're pushing on the far
corner case they're going there at the
kidding they're all over the place just
one example
so nothing stops them we're going to
turn shortly to some questions from the
audience I have a lots of good questions
we'll try to get through as many of them
we can I'd like to have a question
really for each and both of you before
we do that one is sort of unbalanced are
you hopeful for the future of
Afghanistan and what can we the
international community and we Americans
do to try to sustain the gains that have
been made and suppose can I start with
you I am hopeful and I'm hopeful partly
because what Mina's said because I do
know the spirits are in the strength of
Afghan women and I think that comes
across in the book and in the stories of
the women that are interviewed in the
book so that makes me hopeful I also
think that the whole international
community we in the United States as
well as the whole international
community needs to continue to do
whatever we can to support women in
Afghanistan and support the Afghan
people we need to help them build an
economy so people can have jobs so
people can make money so that people can
be become independent and those are the
things that we need to continue to do
but I also was heartened that President
Obama chose to keep our troops there I
think we need to keep the troops there
we need to make sure that they at that
Afghanistan has the security to be able
to build the stability to form their
government and continue to work on what
they're working on I know mrs. Ghani the
new first lady of Afghanistan is very
effective she's a member of our USF gaen
Women's Council that met earlier today
and sent a message to us she's hoping to
build a women's university with women
professors so that still when the
traditional fathers don't want their
daughters to go to university because of
going with men or having men professors
that there'd be an option for women and
I think that's a good way that Americans
could support her and that is to
try to help in that way as she builds
this women's university but obviously
the most important thing is the security
and our troops can help on that Mina
same question to you are you hopeful and
what should we be doing and I agree
because without security Security's a
number thing number one thing without
security you cannot move forward
everything starts collapsing around you
and and we don't want the international
community to leave as well we have
started something as the international
community and we have to continue and
make it really solidified you know make
it happen and making sure the world that
you know we were there not with a 15 or
20 or 30 years and it happened you just
don't want to leave a country in chaos
when it's in chaos and that shows the
failure on the international community
so we have to continue what we're doing
and we have to really pour more money
into development in the military I'm
sorry it's just if if we have capable
people and if people have food on a
table and they have jobs why would you
need military this is a question for me
because I'm not a politician but I'm an
activist so that comes to me all the
time so for me first comes the
development yes we do have to train the
police to a limit we do have to train
dormant military because of our
neighbors but if you have good citizens
and if you don't have hungry citizens
who can be bought by your neighbors or
by any politician or anybody I mean you
will have a stable country but
unfortunately for the past 14 15 years
yes a lot of money has been poured but
it hasn't really been poured into the
real real development side of it it has
been a lot into the military and police
which has not been very effective either
so even now
money a lot of the money has been
allocated to the defense and military
but I think if we could just add to that
and for you know add more money to
development to develop people to give
them jobs to create jobs the other thing
that has happened with the trainings we
train but we don't follow we can train
all we want there should be a follow-up
program maybe up to a year not short
term but long term yeah we can do the
trainings a month two months or then
everybody leaves okay so many women were
trained and so many men and okay big
pictures and done but we have to follow
up if this person really found a job if
the stream if this training was
effective if it wasn't effective then
what should we do to make it effective
because we have already spent a lot of
money and we want to see the result that
successful to everybody to the donor to
the Afghan people to everyone so that's
where I'm coming from I don't want
anybody to leave but to get more money
at it to the development side of it good
food is a security issue as well yes in
fact they think that one of the reasons
the Taliban and and the that was that
little boys were put in these madrasahs
but their parents put him there because
they were hungry and they got fed so
their food ends up being a security
issue as well
I wonder I've been reading this one part
of the book that open I think that's
what what we're talking right about
right now in the rest of the world we
live in a very fast-paced life we want
everything to happen in front of our
eyes we don't think about the future we
don't invest in the future unfortunately
and that needs to change
I'm sure other nations have gone through
this societal change probably hundreds
of years ago
I think it'll happen in Afghanistan we
just have to be patient and not give up
because once you give up you have to
start from scratch all over again yeah
this talking about the the non-security
side and an issue that's very dear to
the heart of us IP this is a question
from Barbara from PAE for both of you
the US government is implementing the
largest rule of law program of its kind
in the world in Afghanistan what should
be its focus in the next five to ten
years particularly as it pertains to
women and girls Meena do you want to
take a shot at that one like I mentioned
earlier the rule of law we have laws we
have many laws needs to be enforced we
have to learn how to enforce laws and
how to use laws I remember I did have a
in my NGO for two months I had a
training for women law lawyers this was
probably ten years ago and it was very
interesting for me to find out that one
of the lawyers she was being abused by
her husband at home but then she would
get out and go to court and try to
defend everybody else so when I found
that out I sat her down I said if you
cannot defend yourself how can you
defend others she started crying she
goes even when I'm standing there trying
to defend others I'm not making it
because the judges that are there they
have already been paid or they're
stronger than me or my are the one who's
across the table from me the other judge
the opponent I mean the the lawyer is
stronger than me and I'm always I always
get defeated this is why I need this
training we need to really focus on
women in judges in the attorneys
starting from the university that's
where we need to start working maybe the
second and third year and your third
year of the law university to start kind
of practicing with them and advocating
for
and teaching them how to defend
themselves first in the house if you
cannot defend yourself within your home
within your own circle then you cannot
defend yourself outside or defend
anybody else and I also know lawyers and
attorneys in Afghanistan that are women
the hill let me tell you they were very
tough but there was just a few there or
in that many and I think we need to
really tap and focus on the younger
generation that are going to be the next
lawyers because the lawyers that are
there from the past maybe 45 or 50 or
that age I'm not trying to discriminate
or anything it's really hard for them to
change their way of work and their way
of implementation and attitude and all
but one thing we can focus on is the
younger generation and teach them to
really be the real lawyer to be in that
court to win to go with an attitude that
I can win so that's what I think
good job next question they're all hard
one of the ones there's sort of two that
are related one comes from Marissa
answer of Georgetown University and is a
question for Mina I'd like to first ask
this one Edie for really again for both
of you this is from Lalit occasi of the
Boswell Afghan News I probably
mispronounced that I apologize there's
been an on-and-off-again talks of peace
talks with the Taliban
on-again-off-again uncertain how it will
go do the women's Bush that you work
with and some of the women in the book
that you know and have talked to and
meanae for you as well are there fears
about the peace process and fears of a
peace agreement between the Afghan
government and the Taliban for what it
will mean for women for what it will
mean for the progress that women of it
since 2001 will you go ahead make peace
with the Taliban I thought the latest I
read is they left of the table the
Taliban did they come back or do you
know is anybody know here they they have
left the Taliban have left the table
recently I think in the last couple days
Andrew Wilder and Scott can answer
Hekmatyar who's one of the folks has
indicated that he is willing to
participate in the Afghan peace process
query whether that will have an impact
on the Taliban so it's I think it's
still on again off again but the
question is really are there some
anxieties there is a lot of anxiety
especially among women through this
peace process and if you look at the
whole picture the overall picture if you
have in the peace council a peace
council that was created years ago when
you have 70 men in five women or six
women how do you arrive at peace because
there was five or six women that were
selected they also cater to whatever
that 65 or 70 men are saying so women
are in minority and women are scared of
course they are
they're an anxiety and not like again
they're fighting this in every way they
can and they are so they don't get
sacrificed you know during the peace
process so they give you know they like
during the Taliban times how where women
were secluded from everything and they
don't want that to happen again because
we have gained so much for the past 14
years and there is no way we will
sacrifice that no way it doesn't matter
what I mean I could I could tell you
this because I come from I always have
these gatherings these women and when
they come from these meetings you should
see their
faces over my dead body that was there
that's how they speak there is no way
I'm gonna give up what I've gained in 14
years and politicians I'm sorry would
sacrifice my right to the Talib in order
to bring peace that is not peace at the
end of the day we are isolating half of
the population so I don't think it will
happen it is just an ongoing thing there
is a lot more involved to it than the
women it is what our neighbor country is
asking for they're asking for a lot of
things that Afghan people are not going
to give up so that's my understanding
the Peace Council we've talked a lot
about women and girls and the important
role they have in Afghan society and the
important role now in peace building one
of the things that came up and the
meeting earlier today was related to
this question it's unsigned as you will
how important do you think efforts are
to reach men and boys in addition to
women and girls if we are to change the
culture and values of the society well
that has to be done for sure reach men
and boys I said earlier in the u.s.
Afghan women's council meeting that one
of my friends said to me I don't know
why you're working with the women it's
the men that need the work
[Laughter]
and there are efforts and we did hear
that in the meeting earlier to work with
men to tell our boys especially to talk
about peace in conflict resolution and
all of those other things but I think
what happened is these boys weren't
parented the ones that are grown up now
that are the terrorists or the Taliban
they didn't have parents who taught them
how to be men and I've taught him how to
you know mother and dad that taught him
how to live instead they were sent to
these madrasas and they were brainwashed
and they were not taught how to get
along with people and that's what a
family a good family does a mother and a
father and that has teach all the
children the boys and the girls how to
get along with other people and and that
other people's lives matter too I agree
with you mrs. Bush but there's one thing
in being in Afghanistan for the past 14
years that I've recognized yes we first
have to work with the boys with the men
because if the men and the boys are
brought up pro-women
then we don't have to exactly right
there's any problems and in the meantime
what has Lord done to these men we have
to look at it this way and I cannot
blame them most of the time it's because
that boy that was born 30 years ago he
was born during the war and you have to
be protective of the women and children
and the girls during the war so he was
then the Taliban came so that was like
an icing on the cake for this whole
thing the mentality so that boy has been
raised with that type of a mentality
protect your woman don't show your woman
don't show the girl and right now we are
going through a social change
and it's going to take time it's gonna
take probably another generation or two
for men to come out and say yeah it's
okay
for really in a very normal way that
we're doing it here you know it's okay
if my daughter goes to work it's okay if
my daughter goes to the movies it's okay
if my daughter does this or that or my
wife right now you see these challenges
it's because of the war the war has
brainwashed the men in Afghanistan and
that generation is still there
and it's going to be there for another
maybe thirty years but it's gonna take a
long time maybe two or three generations
so you could really see the change this
is a related question from Mira a Yazzie
who's a student at George Mason
University it's a little long but it's a
good one as a first-generation Afghan
American I've been raised to learn how
to balance my Afghan heritage with my
Western surroundings given that
Afghanistan has a patriarchal structured
society what clashes or conflicts have
you seen arise as a result of the
resistance to women's equality that some
may view as a Western idea rather than
an Afghan idea and how have you seen
balance created with tradition and this
so-called Western idea of women's
equality and empowerment go it is
beginning to be like jeopardy
well the first thing that's very common
it's the word gender their word gender
in Afghanistan I mean the gender is
equality empowerment between men and
women and all of that I mean we know
what it means it includes male and
female but when you talk about gender
and Ivana son they all talk about what
they all think women they think it's a
Western thing to have equal rights of
women while to be honest with you in
Islam we do have equal rights for women
they're all rights for women there are
good rights for women and what happened
in the beginning when we all first went
everybody went in without doing their
homework everybody brought in the
Western ideas and unloaded in
Afghanistan without thinking what is the
culture what is the acceptance of all of
these things how would people take this
so when we started on these gender
trainings it didn't go very well so you
had to rename these things and and
really let people know what it really
means and as a napkin American when I
have been there I've watched they would
perceive you as an Afghan no problem but
later in the day you know they'll say
okay you're here I know you're helping
me I know you did this for me but you
know what you have a passport you're
going to leave you have that option and
I always tell them yes I have that
option but I'm here no matter what and
and that's one of the reasons these are
all the perceptions because Afghan
people they really have to trust you and
I don't blame them for not trusting
anybody because to be honest everybody
has come in and invaded and left and
ruined and talked so they don't trust
anybody and it has
with the war and the way they have been
treated and now for the past 14 years
yes thanks to international community
thanks to all the donors they have been
there they have pushed issues for women
like for example it politically to be in
the Senate to be in the Parliament to be
in the government I mean the four
ministers so it has been the foreign
push as well not only the government but
still they have these doubts until you
overcome those doubts with the Western
issues they will doubt the Western
issues anything you put forward they
will think twice whether okay whether it
comes from Germany that comes from Egypt
where it comes from America it doesn't
matter as long as it's from a foreign
entity they think twice they think they
just don't want to go for anything
anymore they'll think twice and say yes
or no yeah thank you very much we regret
ibly have come to the end of our time I
want to thank all those who submitted
questions and my apologies to those who
submitted questions we I'd like to turn
to our panelists and just ask if you'd
like a last word before Nancy comes up
the women who are in this book would you
all stand the women he attended her in
the book
and I also want to say I think we've
left too bleak of a picture it's not as
bad as we made it sound today it is
important that we all stay involved as
Americans in Afghanistan it's important
that we keep our troops there and to try
to give Afghanistan's the security and
this space of security as they continue
to build their country and for all the
international community to continue to
do the things they're doing and our
meeting earlier with the US and Afghan
Women's Council one of the things we
thought is so many nonprofits have gone
in maybe we ought to figure out how to
get some for profits in Afghanistan so
baking people can be employed and make
money and try to figure out ways to help
develop the country and so that the
Afghan government can stand up and be
the ones that that take care of things
in Afghanistan you know okay I just want
to add something to all of this when I
saw the book mrs. Bush I'm really
honored as always to be around you thank
you and I'm thankful to the usf young
woman Council they have been done an
incredible job when I saw the book it
reminded me took me back to 14 years ago
so I want to read something to you
I just want to mess up the Honorable
mrs. Bush I would like to thank you on
behalf of Avion men and women for all
the work you have supported and cared
and and the carrier of given the Afghan
women and children you even went to
Bamiyan I do remember those days I gave
my first lobbying speech in Chicago in
2004 and 2004 in front of for 400
American businessmen and women I had to
convince many leaders with my speech to
believe in Afghan women's capacity and
to fund for the projects after a long
speech I ended with the
following sentence with a lot of hope
this is what the Afghan woman says still
after her pain she says I feel like the
thunder the dark days and this storm is
left the Sun is out now I just started
blooming like a rose this Rose needs
tender love and care to fully bloom I do
not want to die again mrs. Bush through
your leadership you have played a major
role in watering these seeds by building
capacity and today you have recognized a
few of the blooming flowers in your book
because 14 years ago it was not possible
and I thank you from my heart
very much
thanks everybody on behalf of all of us
here today and on behalf of u.s.
Institute of Peace
I want to thank mrs. Laura Bush miss
Mina Scherzer Shores Oy and of course
mr. Steve Hadley our chair thank you for
reminding us that after 37 years of war
it will take a long time maybe
generational to fully emerge from that
conflict but that there are
extraordinary signs of progress and and
much hope and so thank you for your
collective passion and inspiration this
afternoon as we look at the the pathway
forward mrs. Bush a special thanks for
you for what you've done for Afghan
women and women around the world with
your work at the bush Institute and
thank you for bringing these beautiful
powerful stories to all of us with your
wonderful nubuck voices of hope and it's
been an honor to host everybody here
today I want to ask everybody to please
stay seated while the panel departs the
stage and please join me in one more
round of thanks and applause for our
wonderful panel
[Applause]